that's not the plan
Julia Beverly I am here welcome welcome
A hip-hop historian publisher
photographer author
what else I like it yeah photographer I
really consider myself a photographer
but I have I wear a lot of hats I do
what needs to be done I was gonna say
get the job done uh so you would
consider like photography your main like
what passion would be like yes ever
since I was probably like 10 or 11 I've
just taken a million photos of
everything going on in my life so I kind
of carried that over into my once I
became a hip-hop you know right
journalist or whatever that's still what
I love to do so uh you're from Orlando
Florida right I am
um shout out to the forest fun fact I
grew up I spent a couple years in San
Bernardino actually California yes
California
so nice was there uh I was like nine
years old rolling the streets in my
little bike you know dodging meth labs
in San Bernardino
um yeah I don't think that was a part of
my experience back then but they
probably were there it's a wild place
man San Bernardino's wild place I've
heard that it's like you know going a
little downhill it has but it's hey we
have shout out to San Bernardino Cyrus
has that's where he represents I went to
I went to school and everything in
Orlando so that's where I came up
started ozone magazine which is a term
for Orlando you know we were trying to
be right or whatever and kind of so for
people who don't know because ozone was
kind of I feel like ahead of its time a
little but in a world in which
there was so much representation
for
media outlets on the East Coast I mean
really it was an East Coast driven thing
hip-hop media as an industry
um even though you know the West Coast
didn't really have a I mean yeah the
West Coast didn't really have anything
to really represent them
um without some sort of East Coast bias
but
um ozone magazine pops up as a magazine
that really championed like a whole new
wave that was going on in southern
hip-hop so what was give me kind of the
rundown on how ozone was started and I'm
gonna say it was almost like not an
accident but I never set out to be like
okay let me represent you know Southern
rap
um I used to read of course the source
double XL
um all these magazines and I would see
the photos and be like how do I become
that photographer because I was I was
really young you know 18 19 just started
got a camera just started going to all
these events I remember the first like
one or one of the very first events I
went to was like this radio show Ja Rule
was headlining or whatever and I shot
you know I'm I'm like broke like 18.
Orlando in Orlando yeah and so shoot the
show and go backstage and they had like
the whole catering tent and it was like
oh I could get like free food
that was like a big incentive so I
always joke about that you know the
industry free food in the industry um
was like half of the attraction at the
time but um so I wanted to shoot for
these magazines so I started like trying
to get in contact with them and you know
being a kid in Orlando and like how do I
get in touch with these you know New
York Publications
um so there was a graphic designer in
Orlando called Merck design is what he
went by and so he had started this
magazine which he actually called it
Orlando source so he literally just he
just kind of took it and put Orlando put
a little Orlando on the top and so I had
got referred to him for his second issue
and that was he wanted me to come you
know work with him the first thing I
said was like I think you probably need
a new logo I don't think yeah you might
get sued take their logo I think they
did actually send a season assistant but
um he changed the logo
um we did that together for about a year
and for me it was just I I had this
envisioned in my head that I was gonna
you know get discovered like the swords
or whoever was gonna be like oh this
photographer is great like let's hire
her and so ultimately what happened like
me and him kind of fell out at a certain
point or didn't we weren't seeing eye to
eye on where we wanted to go with it so
um I had finished I was doing the
creative side he was doing the business
side which is where the conflict came in
because he would be like yeah they paid
they only paid 400 for an ad and I would
find out they paid 700 right we're
supposed to be splitting the money right
you know
anyway um that's how that all kind of
unraveled but we we had gotten to a
point where he said I'm not going to do
this anymore and I had already finished
the next issue and so Mercedes was one
of our street team people and she was
like well why would you stop like why
don't you just change the name I mean
you got magazines already done you know
everybody you've got all the advertisers
and so that's kind of where it started
from because we did already have a base
of like we had a lot of local companies
that would advertise and so originally
even the early issues of ozone um it's
like Orlando music or Florida music
which is very heavily you know Latino
influence you've got a lot of Caribbean
influence so we had a lot of Reggae
artists reggaeton like it was kind of
everything happening what year was the
first issue 2002. who was on the cover
red dog red dog yes he was from Orlando
oh yeah
my Orlando uh hip-hop encyclopedia goes
to uh
Caskey
what's the guy's name I will never with
a street yes miles and south star uh the
dude was in jail with the dreads he cut
him off [__] I played [__] in the club
this song's called [__] n words
wow that's a new one to me I mean like
there was there was a lot of groups that
had like a couple records but yeah
Smiles in southstar Kaya came out of
Kyle actually shot her first album cover
in our office is Kaya from Orlando she's
from Tampa okay that's what I thought
yeah yeah she burned a lot of bridges
yeah everybody out in Tampa I know was
just they just have terrible things to
say about Kaya and I'm like Jesus like I
guess well
all her mug shots in one of our early
issues so she had been arrested like 20
something times and I just thought it
was a great visual so we printed all the
mug shots and I remember I don't know if
it was officially her people but like
somebody ran up on me in the club and
was like
you know and then she ended up I think
she put it out as a mixtape cover or
something like that okay so you did her
favor that's for sure yeah it's crazy
because like uh she's a cool rapper I
mean yeah I mean she had an iconic
record still sampled and getting yeah
for sure I was gonna say like Florida
hip hop in 0203 that's like
there's really not like right now we
think of Florida hip hop and it's just I
mean it's so massive the the state has
blown up between I mean we just had like
three rappers from Tallahassee alone at
the BT radio I just happened to be in
the right place at the right time when
you had I mean T-Pain from Tallahassee
you mean Pitbull Rick Ross Florida
Khalid was a big influence right when we
ultimately ended up doing that because
he has so much roots in Orlando him and
nasty were in Orlando right well early
on to do um or maybe still does Khaled
used to do the temple his birthday bash
every year so every artist you could
think of would come out and it would
just be like really organic like you
know Diddy grabs and like enhances of
you know Jadakiss or whatever this big
party so when we ultimately did the
ozone Awards I had Cali come do the
opening set because that was the like
the inspiration was like his his I was
like just do what you do at your you
know it's your birthday back right so we
had like Trick Daddy and Pitbull and
Ross and uh this is when Ross had
hustling
um so I was just there when a lot of
them had been bubbling for a while and
we're kind of on the precipice of just
breaking you know breaking through and
so when I started interviewing a lot of
people like like a pit bull would talk
about how it was a blessing that he had
never got signed earlier he was like
well the New York labels you know they
ignored me so for so long it forced me
to like build up this fan base I
traveled around I did all these shows
right so you know artists today it's
almost like it's too easy like they
could be very young if they get the
right record then they're they're in the
game right away without without a lot of
them have the history of the struggle
traveling you know staying in shitty
hotels going to a radio station in the
morning to just try to you know for sure
that's all part of the experience 100 so
a lot of the artists were experiencing
the same thing I had experience on the
the journalism side because I had tried
to I mean I did some stuff here and
there like for the source and you know
some little freelance stuff but there
reached a certain point where I I was
kind of like oh like we're actually onto
something here with this magazine I
don't need to try to go right work for a
New York Magazine so a lot of artists
like pitbull or a Pimp C would talk
about the same
experience they had where they were
trying so long to get accepted by New
York and it just never happened and
finally they were like all right I'll
just I'll just do it my own way make my
own did the traditional magazines at the
time
um
were they Payton were they were do they
embrace you because at the time there's
like this weird
like
I don't know man there's like the source
to really turned into like a weirdo
magazine for a little bit and then you
know obviously Elliot Wilson was running
it up running circles around him at XXL
for a sec and you know it felt like such
a competitive space I have some funny
stories about that I mean and so we're
moving a little forward like by this
time you know 2005-ish like you guys
have been up and running from realizing
like there's really some money in this
right
um and I think what showed me too like
the early issues I might send I'd send
like a box to like Montgomery Alabama or
something and I'd send like four boxes
to Miami thinking like oh Miami's a
bigger market and people in Miami I mean
they liked it but they're kind of like
they have you know three radio stations
and they have yeah they have Boomin City
places to go like the artists there
don't really need right a platform
whereas I would get like 100 calls from
Montgomery all these DJs artists people
that want to get down so I started to
see there was a market and you know the
south is full of Tallahassee
Jacksonville you know Birmingham I mean
there's are so many like Tennessee
mid-level markets that just don't have
at that time they didn't have social
media so if they're there's an artist
they're trying to get on they don't have
you to to show people what they look
like so you know they would advertise in
the magazine so I saw that there was a
real Market there so uh Elliott Wilson
um saw him yesterday a couple days ago
so I mean we're cool and stuff but he's
always been one to kind of like take
shots at different people so
funny story about him
um well I remember at one point I would
go to New York and I would like drop off
magazines places so I stopped by double
XL one time just to drop off some
magazines and he was like the only
person in the office I think it was like
eight o'clock in the evening or whatever
and I just remember him he said uh oh
you're not you're not from around here
are you like it was to me it was like
people in New York kind of I don't know
if you meant it to be like like I took
it a certain way I don't know that he
meant it that way but to me somebody
from if I asked somebody where they're
from and they say like Houston or the
Bay right or L.A like I kind of have a
sense of like where they're from and
right what kind of you know environment
they're dealing with and I felt like New
Yorkers had this idea like you're either
from New York or you're not and it's
it's one or the other you know what I
mean that's that's kind of how I
perceived it was like oh you're not from
here so you're just I don't really care
where you're from I don't know where
you're from yeah so that's kind of how I
took it but later on like maybe a couple
years down the road
um we had never been able to get a
distribution deal I I don't know that I
put a whole lot of effort into it but it
was always like a street kind of like
you're getting your own printing done
and you're everything yeah load up the
van drive to you know yeah because I
would see your guys's stuff at like
record stores like small like
independent record stores like I think I
might have saw it at like Tower Records
we eventually did get a distribution
deal so I had been trying there's
there's really at that time there might
have been like two or three Distributors
but there's really only like one big
distributor which is Curtis and they did
you know double XL and source and all
that and I would have thought they were
the same distributor so they were yeah
they were Distributing both
they were Distributing like any
newsstand you go to you know right
pretty much goes through Curtis at least
from from what I recall and I had you
know send them copies of the magazine
they sent us like this standard like
rejection letter or whatever and
um I hired a consultant to try to harass
them and try to get us a distribution
deal but I said something about double
XL in my editorial and Elliot responded
like he he put a little line or
something about ozone or whatever and so
I copied it and sent it because he would
write his little like he was always
taking shots at you know the sauce and
like all this stuff but he said
something about like oh go down south
with the ozone or like it was something
that could be interpreted as like a disc
back to us so I copied it sent it to the
distributor and I don't know if that was
what did it or the consultant or
whatever but we got a distribution deal
and so it kind of so shout out to him
like you know if you're Distributing
this product and they're like you know
now if you're battling with somebody
they're an equal basically so
um but the source I mean I I started I
met boo Rosario
um pretty early on he was a music editor
or one of the music editors at the
source and he did the the photo
galleries in the back so I started
sending him stuff and I would be super
excited if I got like you know my little
so you were getting your picks sometimes
in the back of the source yeah so on a
photography I would send them like
hundreds of pictures and they might pick
you know yeah yeah two or three months
might make it but I'll be excited about
that and I so I met Kim and uh you know
shout out to Kim when she was she was
the editor at that point she had come
down to Miami I think to shoot um Trina
or something and you know I would kind
of throw it out there like you guys
should hire me to you know work this out
like I didn't feel like anyone took that
super seriously but they did start
giving me like a little assignment here
and there and
um that's when they were I think
starting to fall apart as far as the
yeah on the on the business side and
then also the Eminem thing was going on
right right it was it was a lot
happening about